brooklyn with the nets let's dive in
six and seven
without this is since january one and of
course kevin durant right now uh is out
kyrie irving played his first game on
january fifth four and three with him in
the lineup but that durant injury it's
now down to three to five weeks with
that mcl sprain and then the news that
came out today jake fisher of br
reporting that james harden has been
telling players and coaches that he's
gonna test free agency this summer
citing things like weather
taxes having to shoulder the load
without kd even mention things like
steve nash's rotations
i mean it was a lot of information that
came out he said weather in town too
many it's too many lights there was a
lot of lights yeah
when you hear all of that smiley
shaquille o'neal what pops into your
head well obviously he's not happy
because when the team was first
put together they had championship
aspirations and you got one guy's doing
his own thing and
nobody's on the same page
you know first thing i did when i went
to miami's i had a
meeting with my good friend over here
and i sacrificed
i said i've just been through a lot i
don't want to go through it no more
you the man you're in charge this is how
it's going to be
it's how i want to be with you and this
is the place where i want to go so
that's the promise that me and him had
we fulfilled that point we should have
won the first year
but something happened we're not going
to talk about that but we end up winning
the second year but
you know in order to win a championship
you have to sacrifice you have to be on
the same page and everyone has to
like each other we fought we argued me
and dewey was in in the locker room
laughing because like
we never yelled at each other but when
we said something people know what he
was talking about like d-wave would
always come to the big
bench
call out the damn screen i knew he was
talking to me like you know he would
have to check on screen but he just like
caught the screen you don't think they
can do that in brooklyn right now listen
when you got one guy doing his own thing
okay got a guy that's that's really
needed and you know people talking about
it is doing this and doing that he's
like i said he's doing his own thing
he kind of throws the balance of of how
it's supposed to be like when we were in
our mode
we had one balance
we had one voice his voice
and we did everything right body fat pat
riley and all that the culture
one thing one voice
we was able to win got too much going on
so james harden doesn't you know he was
made some promises promise is not being
kept so he's saying hey
i'm out of here this summer and i would
do the same thing about him i think it's
uh also true for james it's a sense of
urgency
like k.d has a ring kyrie has a ring
james
he don't name his getting older right we
know this and and to be to be as
productive as james is right he's pretty
much averaging the triple-double and no
one's talking about it i think it's i
don't know the numbers but i know it's
close 22 8 and 10. right number one the
nba and assists and besides you know him
having a hamstring injury that he had
last year he's been pretty available for
most of his career right right and so
this is sense of urgency time for james
harden so if he said he won a test free
agency that's what it's there for for a
player to be able to test free agency
that's his right and so you know i think
everybody gets so you know on goal oh he
won a test free agency so what i think
he should be able to now you know we
don't know what's going on in the locker
room but what we do know is james harden
has been the consistent for this team
k.d obviously was playing at the mvp
level before he went out but james
harden has been the one every night
that's been there to be able to help
this team stay where they are but they
almost have 30 wins so um let that man
do what he want to do right but he's not
a free agent yet and that's my point is
the fact that like
when you have a contract and you start a
season
and the whole point of them going there
was to win
why are we talking about this right now
maybe third media no but i'm just saying
we're third in the east right now two
games what how many games at it
yeah probably like 29 or 17. you're .5
games you're a half a game out of first
place right now with one of your best
players out with a knee injury and kyrie
only playing on the road
so you could get a ring this year he has
come out in the last week he said that
the refs whistles haven't been
consistent he also said after a recent
game we'd really like kyrie to be here
for all of the games it seems like all
of the issues are coming up at the same
time but as you're saying we're the
middle of the year and you're half a
game out of first so it's it's an
interesting timing and i think a lot of
athletes especially
younger and i'm you know i know james is
getting older but they don't understand
like
these years go by and your opportunities
to win championships
become
less and less when you have an
opportunity you're in third place in the
east in a half a game
you know hey
you guys sound really old right now you
guys i will i'm foreign
together whatever